the following contains spoilers for the
upcoming season on Game of Thrones
hey guys down bring you the second part
of video that I published a few days ago
in this video I'm bringing more deaths
in which some are confirmed by liquid
some of them are confirmed by with
photos while some are only supported by
my theory a theory which is
substantiated and created simply by
putting two and two together by puzzling
out all week photos and event from week
plot let's start with explaining events
that will lead urine to death
and on that journey we will also come to
that sofa bar and emelius and waddle
area and her daughter Tina firstly going
to be captured whereupon are going to be
executed as well in this video it will
also be introduced with that of Cersei
Lannister which is going to be the
result of her marrying urine and partly
of her becoming the mad Queen so as I've
already said let's start with explaining
all events that will lead urine to marry
Cersei and on a journey we will come to
all deaths that I mentioned it's
important for you at this point to know
that Jaime with Lannister army along
with Randall and his star the army will
get ambushed by Daenerys riding dragon
along with her Dothraki horde while they
are marching home with carriages full of
good Foley from Highgarden
whereupon Randall is going to be
executed for his treason for pledging
his army to Lancers cause after this
defeat the only source is a lie Tarly
army will be weak well Lannister army we
cannot safely to be weak but won't be
powerful as it once had been this aligns
between Cersei and Randall along with
Danny's ambush and Randall's that I've
explained in confirmed that's part one
so for more details feel free to check
it out at this point source will be
desperate there are enemies all around
her and Tyrell I will be lost but her
army won't be powerful enough to destroy
all of her enemies that's the moment
which soon we'll have to take advantage
of that's his opportunity to marry Queen
and as leaked photos are confirming
that's an opportunity which urinal grab
with both hands that the moment in each
urine will come to King's Landing after
he successfully defeated Yara along with
the sand snakes that's the moment in
maturing will come and parade his
prisoners and is going to pledge his
army and
inflate 30 but in return sir Sybil had
to marry him
similar dus he had for Daenerys that's
the deal which sir still accept that the
day which will bring her hopes hopes
that her reign is going to last a little
bit longer
that's the deal with Cersei knows she
has to accept or otherwise her reign is
over but let's get a little bit back on
that fleet battle between your gradual
against the R&T and gradually to their
Ironborn fleet support base and sinks in
their army this sleep battle is not a
big surprise since the R&T on only then
is Ella are going to try to retake the
kingdom of the Iron Islands from urine
who has also started building a thousand
ships in previous season however as my
predictions supported by the late plot
and leaked photos a few months ago were
that team Greyjoy's has arrived at
Dragonstone and later had been beaten up
by the I remember man because he either
ran away or was sent out by yar upon
noticing that defeat is certain defeat
in which herb our enemy we are going to
die while hilarious and and her daughter
teen are going to get captured along
with tiara all this came true about a
month ago as I've already showed you
leaked photos of the proof in my
previous videos as you can see from the
photos grr illyrian team will be
captured after urine destroyed their
fleet of inquiry to the streets of
King's Landing which could be considered
as the biggest polar for the upcoming
season from leaked photos we can see
your own Greyjoy and his horse which is
decked out in great-looking faceplate
living yarn chains to the streets full
of King's Landing citizens Kerrville
coming there in hero euron greyjoy
those same citizens that once were
cheering for Joffrey uh Turkey demanded
from sir Ilyn Payne to bring commander
Stark's head Yara won't be the only one
who is going to pray to the streets of
King's Landing
they're also captured delirious Sam and
her daughter teen this seems immature
niece parading that his prisoners will
represent urines parading to the streets
of King's Landing
parading all the way to the red keep
it's now certain that urine is going to
be TR and sand snakes but it's unknown
if he is going to defeat them because of
his experience in three battles or
because he built so many
kids a thousandth of damage he promised
he will and simply outnumber them it's
all certain that urinal pledges are
inflated sirs in the upcoming season but
in return Cersei will had to marry him
similar deal as he had for Daenerys but
at that time his siblings were faster in
this very moment during earthly photos
which could confirm faith Aviara
illyrian teen after they paraded through
the streets of King's Landing but in my
opinion with two sick villains such as
urine and Cersei I don't even want to
imagine what's going to happen to them
especially to sense makes which are more
flies are going to be brutally tortured
by Cersei as a revenge for killing her
daughter Myrcella whereupon they are
going to be executed to me personally
the fact that urine is going to defeat
er and send snakes in a fleet battle
isn't surprising at all since urine
gradua is violent predictable a cunning
strategist and the warrior did possess
pro-military tactic skills urine has
spanned the last few years as a pirate
reading from old town two cards and
beyond while his long ship by the name
of silence is the most famous ship
mostly because of the fact that silence
is crewed by mules as a result of urine
ripping out their tongues only in favour
to achieve silence of his ship as urine
said himself
I needed silence it's going to be
interesting to see cruel fury longship
especially now that they also know that
Conor McGregor will be one of the
pirates belonging to urine screw so yeah
urines victory over yards please
supported by sand snakes it's not
surprising for me but while they are is
going to be captured I don't think she
is going to be executed while on the
other hand I'm sure that captured alaria
saying it's your daughter teen are going
to be brutally tortured by Cersei
whereupon they're going to be executed
in this video so far they've had that so
Illaria tying Obara Nymeria sand now
let's focus on that of two villains that
search in urine while dazzle sense
stakes are confirmed by like plot and
Lee photos that of your inserts here are
corroborated only by my theory theory
which is as I've said in the beginning
of this video
substantiate it and created simply
by putting two and two together by
puzzling out all the photos and events
that are going to happen in the upcoming
season based on leaked plot a tear which
I've already brought to you guys in one
of my previous videos with a little
change is time this theory of mine would
start at the scene from dragon pit in
which all main characters will attend
and by the way is confirmed on that
meeting 17 major characters are going to
attend which makes these scenes having a
big role in season 7 and the outcome of
that meeting which is going to be
organized by Denise and John in favor to
show all the lords the real trash that's
all of them are facing in favor to be
knighted all their armies to stand a
chance against the undead army is going
to have a great importance for the
events to come in season 8 considering
that most probably this scene is going
to be released in season 7 finale while
all Lords and powerful people are going
to agree with the nearest and will agree
to unite all of their armies all but
Cersei Cersei one consider the situation
is everyone else's Cersei will welcome
the undead army in her opinion the White
Walkers along with their white horde are
going to defeat all of her enemies which
would only benefit her according to
leaked plot Jaime will come to Cersei
and ask your permission to lead
Lannister army to the north to join the
great battle to join all other armies
but serviceable refused his request
along with telling him her opinion about
the undead army which I've already told
you a few moments ago after regime is
going to be speechless Jaime won't
believe what she just said
additionally by my theory in that moment
Cersei will also announce to Jaime that
she is going to marry urine in a few
days meanwhile according to leaked plot
Jaime will before search his confession
already means the Tyrion and Davos
meeting mysterion is going to try to
convince his brother Jaime to join him
to join the we can call it good side but
Jamie is going to refuse with a
statement that he's a Lannister and that
he would never betray his sister
well that's Jamie's opinion before
knowing sources opinion about the undead
army and before services announcement
about marrying urine as a result of all
of that Jaime will decide to kill his
once below
and lover Jamie who is also known by the
nickname of king of lair will now become
a queen slayer but once again Jamie will
save a lot of innocent lives let's get
back on the Dame it's Cersei is going to
be killed
let's get back on the events that will
happen earlier that day by my theory
Jaime disappointed by search his opinion
we'll think about leaving King's Landing
and support Dillon side with his
experience in leading army that same day
Cersei will get married to her and
Greyjoy a marriage in which LA won't
exist a marriage which serves to accept
only to get a bigger army while Jaime
will finish his preparations to leave
King's Landing just before Jamie leaves
King's Landing he's going to feel the
need to see Cersei once again and to
tell her that he is leaning and he's
going to support a lame Excite while
Cersei will show her feelings
not to mention by my theory Cersei will
mock him sir she will tell him that she
doesn't need him anymore that she now
has her husband husband who has the
biggest fleet and solid amount of farmy
to support her Jaime frustrated by those
search statements encouraged by the fact
that she and urine won't send their
armies to the north armies that the
links I desperately needs Jaime will
decide killer to strangle Cersei to
death along with killing urine most
likely with someone else's help
after that Jaime will join the we can
call it war between life and death
along with Lannister army if this theory
comes shoe which I truly believe it well
it would also fit perfectly to Game of
Thrones series enter Jaime's whole life
story as well in conclusion that of the
sand snakes is confirmed while that of
Cersei and yearn is only supported by my
theory theory which is simply product of
my mind or should I call it overthinking
a theory which might but also might much
come true there are also dead so
dangerous stark and towards Sameer but I
won't talk about that again because I've
already made a video about it but in
case you didn't feel free to check it
out and don't forget to participate in
brand new giveaway in which you have a
chance to win hundred dollar Amazon gift
card link is in description down below
hope you guys enjoy this video if it is
please make sure to subscribe to our
Channel
and I hope to see in the next beat
[Music]
you